bonjour william heinz merci de répondre
à nos questions par téléphone à nos
questions ce matin la vaccination
obligatoire de voir nécessaire choix
éthique ou privation des libertés
individuelles
alors c'est une grande question mais
j'ai effectivement comme l'a dit votre
collègue juste avant dans son reportage
et la vaccination du nettoyage et déjà
pour un certain nombre de maladies à
l'hôpital notamment l'hépatite b n'a pas
mentionné ce qu'on trouve normal un
genre là je parle en mon nom propre un
c'est à quelque chose qu'on a discuté au
sein des directions du câble secret pas
grand monde et du côté médical de voir
telle vaccination du gâteau harkis et
les principes de protéger les autres qui
est au fondement de notre actif de
soignants effectivement de la question
d'aller essayer de vivre en société et
peu le même principe que la vaccination
obligatoire pour accéder à l'école de la
trèche et que tout le monde se trouve ça
fait rien position légère pour permettre
aux plus fragiles d'entre eux mieux
qu'il peut être en avril dernier la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme a
reconnu que l'obligation vaccinale
constituer une ingérence dans l'exercice
du droit au respect de la vie privée
mais dans le même temps en vertu du
principe de la solidarité sociale
l'obligation vaccinale était
proportionnée au but que son 1 la
protection de la santé et de la
protection des droits d'autrui et je
sais que c'est juridique mais vous en
tant qu'interne votre position c'est
quoi
moi personnellement c'est celle que vous
serez taxe obligatoire après dans les
chiffres ont été annoncés qu'ils aient
des chatons 10 % de personnel d'accueil
et de 30% en juillet des chiffres
portent peu près tous les états du comté
de france et il faut pas oublier que là
dedans il ya quand même parce qu'elle
était de non-accès aux actions étant
donné que les stocks ont été faits qui
ont été sur les derniers mois et qu'à
chaque fois qu'il ya des places petit
libère pas finie elle comprit l'unaf et
donc je pense qu'il faut pas non plus se
dire qu'il ya 30 % des femmes contre les
choses de faire courir un risque et leur
passion et la question de l'accueil mais
à la campagne de vaccination stade
pourquoi le personnel
médical ou paramédical notamment dans
les ehpad ans l'a vu dans le reportage
d'amaya soubelet pourquoi est-ce que ce
personnel là n'est pas encore
entièrement vacciner manque de temps
donc de dose ou simplement défiance
derrière une part de problèmes
d'organisation qui fait que là on
commence à enfin rattraper le retard et
après il ya une part de défiance bien
mais c'est aussi lié au fait que la
communication est plus que raqueter sur
les sujets des vaccins on a vu mon avis
mon avis on admire les tranches d'âge on
à la polémique entre qu'un petit deux
axes manif avocat respecté raf toute la
communication politique au sujet de la
stratégie vaccinale au pied du col
depuis plus d'un an je pense à a fait
perdre la confiance d'une partie de la
population dans les autorités sanitaires
et scientifiques et ce qui pour moi
personnellement de les plus grands de
préjudices causés par ce qu vie d'une
ligne et cette perte totale de confiance
d'une partie de la population dans une
institution du fait d'une communication
qui était totalement brouillonne pendant
très longtemps mais fallait faire quoi
alors fallait rendre la vaccination
obligatoire dès le départ les français
auraient horaires aller si je puis dire
pendant quinze jours on en aurait plus
entendu parler et puis ça aurait roulé
c'est ça il ya une différence entre les
français les camions déjà nous on a
d'évacuer handicapés en tant que
soignant qui ne font pas les lacunes
victoire de tout le monde
ensuite je suis bien contente pas être
livrés à compter je n'ai pas tout donné
en mai à l'heure d'aujourd'hui quand un
tag sous couvert de vous rendre les
choses obligatoire et surtout au vu de
l'évolution des variétés ranspach à
crédit parce que
pour parler des personnes et des ehpad
c'est un risque que de continuer à
soigner des personnes vulnérables sans
être vaccinés c'est ça oui mais un
principe est d'être un prof d'école qui
n'a jamais été vaccinés contre la
rougeole et paul a reculé alors que
certains pays d'europe je pense
notamment à l'italie ont déjà adopté la
vaccination obligatoire pour le
personnel soignant à moscou ans
également est ce qu'il est prouvé que si
on vaccine tout le personnel soignant ça
peut endiguer la propagation du virus
la virus au niveau de la france entière
nous on n'est pas à prendre à une
population suffisamment grande de
l'autre n'en transportait un impact sur
la population entière
par contre sur le risque qui est offert
aux patients en soigne et qui est de
faire simple fait de des patients sont
dans une situation de plus grande
fragilité pavillon limites notamment de
l'étudiant je gardais en effet pas des
gens on paie les résidents côtoient
n'est plus ce sont des soignants de
l'ehpad mon si vos protégés c'est le
petit nom vacciner c'est sûr nous nous
protège je me permets de vous donner de
risques on n'atteint jamais avec lui et
on avait des bandes moins de risque
qu'ils soient contaminés
en tout cas on s'inquiète beaucoup indus
variante delta
les politiques les médias également les
français très certainement
est ce que vous vous craignez une
quatrième vague de qu'ovide cet automne
notamment à cause de ce variant à delta
alors chamois je suis chirurgien donc
ces questions deux variantes de risques
infectieux relatifs je me garderai bien
de les prendre en faute sur la question
et je ne maîtrise absolument pas et
c'est là que je refuse de faire comme
certains me connais qui se prononce à
tort et à travers sur un des sujets qui
ne sont pas claires de qualité donc je
me répondre ils paraissent pas parce que
je suis incapable de jeu merci pour
votre honnêteté williams heinz merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes directeur
général de l'irsn et l'intersyndicat
national des internes